if you rotate a ball around one axis then another it's not the same as doing the two rotations in the reverse order
today in kiss in the classroom we'll see what this ball has to do with quantum computers and one of the most famous
principles of quantum mechanics the uncertainty
principle welcome to kissk in the classroom a video series where we break down a fundamental concept that you
might encounter in a Quantum Computing related course each video is accompanied by an interactive module Linked In the
description below so be sure to check that out today we're talking about the Heisenberg uncertainty principle if
you've heard about it before you may have also heard the old joke about Heisenberg one day he was pulled over while driving and the cop asked him do
you know how fast you were going Heisenberg responded no but I know exactly where I am this is kind of
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle in a nutshell you can't simultaneously know about a particle's position and momentum
with perfect Precision it's often written like this Delta x * Delta p is greater than
or equal to h/ 2 where Delta X and Delta P are the
uncertainties in the position and momentum and H is a tiny fundamental constant in quantum mechanics
Heisenberg came up with this inequality back in 1927 when he was imagining how to measure the position of an electron if
you bounced a photon off of it to see where it is that Photon would inevitably kick the electron and disturb its
momentum this isn't just a statement about measurements disturbing a system it tells us that there are fundamental
limits to how much we can learn about nature this is one example of a broader principle called complimentarity which
says that certain aspects of nature are incompatible with one another and can't be observed
simultaneously for example Quantum objects sometimes behave like their particles and sometimes like their waves
but you can't observe both behaviors simultaneously Heisenberg's position and momentum relation covered just one of
many sets of complementary features this inherent uncertainty has to do with how we View Property like
position and momentum in quantum mechanics instead of thinking of X and P as variables or intrinsic properties
that each particle possesses in quantum mechanics position and momentum are operators they're not properties of a
system but things you can do to a system learning about a particle's position now requires you to perform an
operation on that system and make a measurement this operation could affect the outcome of other subsequent
operations as an analogy think about a piece of dry wood it has many properties like its
position size shape it also has the property of being burnable and being floatable in water if this wood were a
Quantum object these wouldn't be properties that you could just know a priority instead we say they're
observables things you can learn about the system if you perform some operation on it so you would need to apply burn
burnability or floatability operators which would require actually trying to burn the wood or putting it in
water to see if it floats now the outcome of each of these operators depends on the order you apply them if
you first test burnability the wood will burn to Ash and you won't be able to test to see if it floats but if you test
floatability first then it'll be too wet to burn we say that the burnability and
floatability operators don't don't commute the order of operations matters this leads to a fundamental
limit to how well these two observables can be known about the piece of wood since we can't say for sure whether it's
burnable or floatable without knowing the context of that measurement now of course with an actual piece of wood you
could cut it in half and test both those properties simultaneously but you can't do anything like that with a Quantum particle this
analogy to Wood is is just that an analogy uncertainty is a uniquely Quantum thing X and P also don't commute
and this property of non-c commuity is what leads to Heisenberg's uncertainty principle in general any two operators
that don't commute will have their own uncertainty principle the general form of the uncertainty principle can be
written like this Delta a * Delta
B is greater than or equal to
12 time there's a and b where
this bracket is called the
commutator and that's equal to the difference between applying first a then
B and applying first B then a these angle brackets
here signal that you're taking What's called the expectation value of what's inside basically if you made the same
measurement many many times the expectation value is the average value of all those measurements today we're
going to actually test and verify this uncertainty principle on an IBM quantum computer we'll look at three different
observables of a cubit show that their operators don't commute and then finally we'll be able to prove that the
uncertainty principle holds holds for these Cubit observables first a brief aside about a helpful way to visualize the quantum
state of a cubit it can be represented by a vector pointing to some place on a sphere called The Block sphere I covered
this in a previous video which is linked in the description but I'll just give you a quick recap here too here's the
block sphere each Vector is parameterized by two angles Theta and F
the state zero is on the North pole and the state one is on the South Pole and an equal superposition of 0 and one is
somewhere along the Equator where f is equal to the relative phase between the two parts of the
superposition so this state here would be equal
to 1 / < tk2 0 + e to the I 1 where I is that
phase when we measure an observable of the Cubit the result is always one of two options corresponding to the two
possible states of the Cubit for the experiment we're about to do we'll look at three observables and
their corresponding operators X Y and Z when you measure any of these observables you get either plus one or
minus one with a probability for each that depends on the angle between the cubit's vector on the Block sphere and
the measurement axis as you might expect Z measures along the Z axis X along X
and Y along y now remember we're talking about observables because with a Quantum
system we can no longer just know things about the system without measuring them
and each observable has a corresponding operation because measurements require operations it might not be obvious but
it turns out that the operation called operators that correspond to each of these observables x y and z are
rotations of Pi around their respective axes so X is a rotation around X Y
around Y and Z around Z so to see if these operators commute or not we can check to see if rotations
on a sphere commute if they do the uncertainty principle won't apply and we would be able to know X Y and Z about a cubit
with perfect Precision if they don't commute then we'll be able to find a new uncertainty relation for the Cubit watch
the point on this ball as I rotate first around X and then around y it ends up
here now let's try it in the reverse order so I rotate first around Y and
then around X it ends up over here so they definitely don't commute that means
we can't simultaneously know a cubit's exact X Y and Z values will have an
uncertainty relation we'll gloss over the details here but we end up with three different uncertainty
relations so we have Delta x * Delta Y
is greater than or equal to Z Delta y Delta Z is greater than or
equal to X and Delta Z Delta X greater than or equal
to Y so the product of any two of these uncertainties is always greater than or
equal to the expectation value of the third observable let's use kcit to see what
happens when we try to measure both Z and X of the state zero measuring Z is easy it's the so-called standard basis
of the quantum computer measurements are always along Z by default but to measure X we need to perform something called a
basis change basically rotating the Bloss sphere so that X is now pointing up where is z used to point to do this
we use a hadamard gate so the full Quantum circuit will look like this we measure in Z apply the hadamard
and then measure an X if we use the kcit Primitive sampler to run this experiment many times we end
up with a histogram of measurement outcomes that looks like this for the Z
measurement and like this for the measurement in X so as you can see we measured the
Cubit to be in the zero State along Z with pretty close to 100% certainty but
along X we knew basically nothing about the Cubit state it was measured to be either zero or one with equal
probability meaning our UNC C in X was about as big as it can be that gives us
a little sense for this tradeoff of uncertainties but we can do a bit better on our quantum computer we can use a
kcit primitive called estimator to find the expectation values of our observables X Y and Z and the
uncertainty in each let's try it for the state pointing in the plus X Direction on the Block sphere we'll use estimator
to calculate the uncertainties in x and z for this state and the expectation value of
y with this state we get this result from kcit when we take the product of the two
uncertainties in X and Y we see that as expected it's larger than the absolute
value of the expectation value of y but this was just for one particular State we want to make sure this inequality
holds true for all Cubit States so let's use estimator again but this time we'll ask it to scan through the values of a
parameter and to find the expectation values at every single parameter value we give it here the parameter we want to
scan is the angle Theta on the Block sphere so that we check the inequality for all the Cubit states that lie on
this Arc that intersects the XZ plane when we do this we get a plot as a function of the angle Theta the red
curve is the product of the two uncertainties and the orange curve is the expectation value of y as expected
the product of the uncertainties in x and z are much higher than the expectation value of y but that wasn't
too hard to satisfy the inequality because the expectation value of y was so low it was Zero for all the states on
this Arc let's do a similar scan through the Theta values but instead of scanning in the XZ plane we'll set 5 equal to pi/
4 so we're looking at the Cubit states that lie on a different arc on the sphere here we see the inequality is
tested a bit more since the orange curve and the red curve are closer together but the red is always above the orange
and the uncertainty principle still holds we haven't checked all the states yet but hopefully you're starting to get
the idea there's a fundamental unknowability about any two complimentary aspects of a Quantum
System including this Cubit we've been using the uncertainty principle forces us to confront the fact that no matter
how hard we try no matter how clever our measurements are we will never know everything with perfect Precision
there's no getting around it really if you don't believe me or even if you do I challenge you go check out the module
Linked In the description and try to beat the uncertainty principle thanks for watching and I'll see you next time